When your sink or bathtub is clogged and backing
up with water, rather than reaching for harsh
chemical drain cleaners, try reaching for
your toilet plunger first. Place the plunger
over the open drain and work it back and forth
the same way you’d unclog a toilet. Within
a few seconds, the clog will disappear, allowing
your sink to drain normally, saving you time
and money.
An open cut, or blemish, is an invitation
for infection, and if you don’t have antibiotic
ointments handy, you might be surprised by
what you can use instead. Honey has antiseptic
properties that fight all kinds of bacteria.
So just drop a dab of honey over your wound,
then cover it with something like a band-aid.
The honey fights off infections, and helps
speed the healing process as well.
If your trampoline is an eye sore, and the
uncovered springs are an accident just waiting
to happen, why not fix both problems at once
with some cheap pool noodles. Simply cut sections
a little longer than the springs, then push
the them through the holes in the centers
so they make a nice snug fit. Now hook the
ends of the springs back onto the tramp, and
repeat the process with the others. If you
alternate the colors, you’ll end up with
a custom pattern that will give a new life
to your old tramp. Kids will think it’s
way more fun, and now your springs are padded,
and protected from the elements as well.
When you’re taking out the trash, a full
garbage bag isn’t a big deal if your trash
bags have built in handle ties. But what if
you’re trying to save money and using the
cheaper variety? When they’re full, there’s
hardly anything to work with, and tying them
off seems nearly impossible. But it doesn’t
have to be. Just gather opposite sides at
the top to form little handles, then spin
the bag around 4 to 5 times. This will twist
the handles to the point where they can be
tied together easily. And now you can enjoy
the convenience of handle tie trash bags,
without having to pay for the more expensive
brands.
Before you go on vacation, try putting some
leftover juice in the freezer until it freezes
completely solid. This way, it will stay in
place even with the bottle upside down. Now
cut the top off another bottle and push the
two together so they lock in place. Put the
container back in the freezer with the frozen
juice at the top, and now you’ve got a modest
little device that will help save you from
food poisoning. When you get back from your
trip, simply open the freezer and check to
see if the juice is still at the top. If it
is, then your power stayed on the entire time,
and your food is still safe to eat. But if
the juice is at the bottom, that means the
freezer lost power, and everything thawed
out long enough to start growing harmful food
poisoning bacteria.
Well now you know 5 more tricks that will
help save you money, and make your life a
little easier.
If you liked this project, perhaps you’ll like
some of my others. Check them out
at www.thekingofrandom.com